Have you ever looked out the window when you
should have been working or studying?
What if your whole job was to just to study
the sky?
Hey plasmids, Trace here for DNews.
Radar as we know it was invented in the mid-1930s
to detect airplanes before they could drop
their bombs.
Basically, radar shoots radio waves out into
the world, and if those waves bounce off something
and make it back to the dish, engineers, or
now computers, could triangulate the position
and size of the thing.
By the late 1970s, radar had gotten so sensitive,
that with the right equipment, scientists
could try to bounce waves off all sorts of
things, even, the smallest of things... electrons
and ions in the upper atmosphere.
This is great, because scientists wanted to
know what exactly those beautiful auroras
we could see at night were made of, and what
the sun was doing to our planet all day, every
day.
So the European Incoherent Scatter Scientific
Association built the EISCAT Svalbard Radar
in 1996.
Its goal is to study the interaction between
the sun and Earth’s atmosphere… using
radar.
built EISCAT, the European Incoherent Scatter
Facility on Svalbard in 1981.
Its goal is to study the interaction between
the sun and Earth's atmosphere... using radar.
This is a very potent radar system.
We have at this site two big parabolic dishes.
One dish is 42m in diameter, and the second
dish is 32m in diameter.
The power amplifier that are using has a peak
power of 1MW.
We need this because what we are studying
is these free electrons at 100km.
First, they are far away, and these are just
free electrons, so they are very, very tiny.
I'm the manager of the EISCAT Radar, and also
working at HQ.
My title is Radar Systems Supervisor.
These massive dishes sit on a Svalbardian
mountaintop just to measure the plasma surging
through our upper atmosphere.
Plasma is ionized (or electrically-charged)
gas...
The ions we mostly looking at is oxygen, nitrogen
and so on.
Looking at how many free electrons do we have,
and also what kind of ion species we actually
have up in the ionosphere.
The plasma originates from the sun's corona,
and is pulled down onto the poles of Earth
by our planetary magnetic field.
At that point, the ions and electrons interact
with the molecules in our atmosphere, exciting
them and causing the beautiful lights that
we call aurora.
The principle is almost like an old television
screen, where you have the phosphorus and
you have the electron beam that's impinging
on the phosphorus, and it starts to glow.
In fact, they use old television components
to suck in all this information.
As it stands now, their components are literally
"off the shelf" 100 kilowatt analog television
transmitters linked together!
They attach those to a giant, movable antenna
dish and Voila, aurora-sensitive radar.
Mostly of the power that we are transmitting
is just going out to outer space, but we have
still some power that are reflected back,
and this power we can then detect with our
big antennas.
We are able to detect very, very small objects.
In principle, just one thing in short, we
are able to detect a small ... like a ball
bearing at 200km, so the system is very, very
sensitive.
Because they can detect these ball bearings,
the EISCAT dishes can be used to detect space
junk, too, but mostly they're looking for
space weather.
Mostly what we can learn is how the solar
winds are interacting with our near atmosphere.
A solar cycle is 11 years between the peaks
on the sun spots, so we have good data that
the scientists can use for this kind of ... looking
into models, and so on.
Basically, EISCAT is just like your local
weather radar, but for SPACE.
Scientists all over the world pay to access
this radar data and draw conclusions for their
own studies.
See, EISCAT isn't studying the data themselves
per se, they're just taking measurements.
We are pushing the technology and of course
this is one good thing, but again this is
basic research.
When you do the research today, it's very
difficult to actually say what will be the
outcome.
This is basic science on a planetary scale.
Basic research, is also called pure research,
because they're not working under a hypothesis,
just gathering information.
EISCAT's datasets are massive, and comprehensive.
Just like with early weather monitoring, more
data, more better.
So EISCAT ran for a whole year, to provide
a baseline for what the sun does to our planet's
atmosphere EVERY.
DAY. Because before that, we had no idea!
Today they are all talking about going to
Mars.
When you're going to Mars, then you need to
know the space weather.
Where this plasma [blobs 00:09:06] will heat
then and so on.
If not then you're in big danger I should
say.
This is one of this thing that actually you
can use this facility for, or the data set
we have accumulated for 35 years to be able
to make this space weather predictions.
Basic research like this helps us understand
the world around us, or in this case, the
world above us.
That's how it is.
You have always to show that you have our
customers, the scientists around.
If you can show that and show that they are
doing sensible research that has some value,
then hopefully you also will get them on this
to actually do it.
We've been talking about our trip to Svalbard
for months, but if you missed it -- we went
to visit the Svalbard Global Seed Vault, also
called the Doomsday Vault.
It was so.
Amazing.
Check out how we're going to secure the future
of our food, here.
Have you ever seen an aurora?
I saw one once.
If you have, tell us about it down in the
comments below and make sure you subscribe
so that you get more DNews.